I'm Will Smith I'm Joel Edgerton
Edgerton and we're doing the wired
autocomplete interview what is Will
Smith's full name
Willard Carroll c8r roll20
you when they say my kick they mean like
what what I don't like like what would I
see it go it yeah that's probably like
what is Will Smith personality morose
melancholy all right it's very quietly
spoken yeah you know that much energy
he's not very positive
what is Will Smith allergic to in hitch
no you know it's funny there's a story
in hitch that allergic reaction was
based on a real allergic reaction I had
yeah what they just used it in the movie
okay yeah what year did Will Smith get
jiggy with it 98 is that about right
something somewhere in there no but I
have no clue
yeah all right well Smith's favorite
food let me see have you been paying
attention all those times we were eating
together right well you know crafty I
just took you out to a nice restaurant
the other day there's a tie between
sushi and the Thanksgiving meal
whoo-hoo joel edgerton who is joe
editing yes we'll get this one on a
deeper level raise your spirits spirits
were like whoo particulate yeah yes
criminal my second page third page maybe
nadie
yeah nadie there you got a first man who
does joel edgerton uh-oh look like Oh Oh
some people think I look like a young
Albert Finney which I'm like yeah yeah
and I also look like a bit like a potato
potato yeah yeah brother Nash and Nash
Edgerton yeah Nash Edgerton is a way
better name than joy
it minute Nash Edgerton it just sounds
like he's gonna do something in trouble
joel edgerton is in a ton of makeup in
bright tragically what did joel edgerton
play in Star Wars oh I played a moisture
farmer called
Oh and loves moisture farmer Owen Lars
yeah Wow how are you related to Luke
Skywalker I'm like a fan don't tell this
yeah yeah and you have to read the
question this Will Smith I told you he
doesn't listen I'm one quick question
when people are talking to you and you
look like your listener what are you
actually doing whose Will Smith me who's
Will Smith's son Trey and Jaden
who's Will Smith's friend on Fresh
Prince a lot of people my friends jazz
who played Will Smith's girlfriend Fresh
Prince Neal long played my girlfriend
for a while Tyra played my girlfriend
literally if you were black acting in
Hollywood during that time you played my
girlfriend honey my mister is Will
Smith's best friend Jada you open know
that's the only person I'm not gonna be
jealous about
who is Will Smith just the two of us oh
that was beautiful you I don't know if
you know that you were in Australia
during that time when Trey was born it
was like a deep heartfelt daddy song
that's what people searched huh alright
one more car
how tall is joel edgerton 511 come on
come on 510 and a half
how old is joel edgerton old
43 43 yeah yeah I'm gonna be 50 next
year yeah how to pronounce joel edgerton
agitant
a guitar jetan kateri confidence a
direct eye contact educated how to
contact joel edgerton oh could get me
trip well I will
everybody's talking over